GOOD NEWS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BUT BAD NEWS FOR
DEMOCRATS.
HERE WITH REACTION IS THE HOST
OF MORNINGS WITH MARIA ON THE
FOX BUSINESS CHANNEL.
ALSO, I HAVE TO ADMIT MY
FAVORITE HOUR YOU DO IS RIGHT
HERE ON THIS CHANNEL, YOU HAVE
THE BEST INTERVIEWS, AND I CAN
NEVER HAVE YOU ON THE SHOW
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO GET UP AT
1:00, 2:00 IN THE MORNING.
I DON'T GO TO BED UNTIL YOU AND
PETER DOOCY GET UP.
SO YOU GUYS COME I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU DO IT.
BUT YOU DO A GREAT SHOW HERE.
YOU HAVE BEEN ALL OVER THIS.
YOU HAVE DONE A PHENOMENAL JOB,
GREAT INTERVIEWS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
LAYER VERSUS TRUTH TELLER, NUNEZ
VERSUS SCHIFF.
>> IT IS PRETTY INCREDIBLE,
ADAM SCHIFF'S OFFICE AS YOU
POINTED OUT, IT IS WORSE THAN
LIES, SEAN, THESE ARE CRIMES
COMMITTED.
PEOPLE WILL BE PROSECUTED FOR
THIS, EVEN IF YOU BELIEVE, THAT
THERE IS A CREDIBLE REASON TO
START AN INVESTIGATION INTO
DONALD TRUMP, A COUNTER
INVESTIGATION.
IT DIED WITHIN WEEKS.
IT DIED WITHIN WEEKS BECAUSE
THERE WERE TRANSCRIPTS OF
UNDERCOVER DOJ AGENTS, FBI
AGENTS RUNNING INTO PEOPLE LIKE
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS, SAM CLOVIS,
CARTER PAGE, AND THOSE DOCUMENTS
WERE THE EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE
THAT THEY DID NOT SEND TO THE
FISA COURT.
I THINK THIS BLOWS UP BIGGER
THAN IT IS RIGHT NOW.
WHEN OBVIOUSLY JOHN DURHAM COMES
OUT WITH THE FINDINGS BUT
LEADING INTO THAT, ALL THE
ATTENTION WILL BE WHAT HAPPEN
BEFORE JULY 2016.
THE LIE THAT THE FBI HAS BEEN
TELLING US THE COUNTER
INVESTIGATION BEGAN IN
JULY 2016, WE KNOW THAT IS NOT
TRUE.
IN FACT IN THE IG REPORT AND
NOBODY TALKED ABOUT THIS.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS STUNNING.
IN THE IG REPORT, IT SAYS
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS HIRED BY
FUSING GPS IN MAY OF 2016.
MAY 2016.
>> Sean: HOLD UP, THIS WAS
KIMBERLEY STRASSEL'S FINE LAST
WEEK.
AND I HONED IN ON IT AS WELL.
THEY ARE SAYING THE OFFICIAL
INVESTIGATION BEGAN JULY 3031.
>> WE WE KNOW THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
BECAUSE CARTER PAGE WAS INVITEDI
BECAUSE CARTER PAGE WAS INVITEDN
CAMBRIDGE AND GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS WAS TOLD GO TO
ROME, MEET THIS GUY JOSEPH AND
HE DROPPED A BOMB THAT RUSSIA
HAD HILLARY CLINTON'S EMAIL.
THAT WAS IN APRIL 2016.
SO THERE WAS A LOT OF INFORMANTS
INFORMANTS, THE SAME INFORMANT
SPIES THAT HAVE WORKED WITH THE
FBI AND CIA FOR YEARS.
WESTERN INTEL.
THOSE ARE THE SPIES WE ARE
RUNNING INTO COMMUNITY BUT IF
THEY COULD WHO REMOTELY ATTACHED
TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AS YOU
SAID EARLIER JUST TO GET A
WINDOW INTO A TRUMP STRATEGY.
SO THE LIES ARE REAL.
PEOPLE WILL BE PROSECUTED, AND
YOU ARE LOOKING AT CRIMES NOT
ONLY AGAINST CARTER PAGE, BUT
AGAINST A SITTING PRESIDENT,
DULY ELECTED AS YOU SAID.
>> Sean: IT IS ALSO REALLY
AMAZING TO ME AND ALL OF THIS IS
THAT THERE WERE A FEW OF US THAT
WERE RIGHT.
AND FOX BUSINESS NETWORK AND YOU
ARE HERE ON WEEKENDS WITH US ON
THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL, BUT IT WAS
YOU, LOU DOBBS, STUART VARNEY
MALL THREE HAVE DONE A
PHENOMENAL JOB IN EXPOSING THIS.
WHERE IS THE REST OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE SO-CALLED
MEDIA HERE?
>> I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT BECAUSE THE LEFT
WING MEDIA HAS BECOME AN
ATTACHMENT IN ARM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I HAVE BEEN SAYING NOW FOR
SEVERAL YEARS, IT ANYBODY ON
EITHER SIDE OF THE AISLE HAS TO
BE OUTRAGED BY THIS.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN
POSITIONS OF POWER PUTTING THEIR
FINGER ON THE SCALE AND TRYING
TO CHANGE WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE VOTED FOR IT.
THIS IS A DEMOCRACY, AND WE HAVE
FREEDOM TO ELECT THEIR LEADER.
WHAT THEY DID IS TRY TO GET IN
FRONT OF THAT.
THAT IS WHY I FIND OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY NOBODY ELSE IN THE
MEDIA WANTS TO BUY EVEN PERCENT
THAT COME A CRIMINAL IS THE FACT
THE DEMOCRATS REFUSED TO FOCUS
ON THAT.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
CALLING FOR IMPEACHMENT ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO TRY TO TAKE
DONALD TRUMP DOWN FROM THE
GET-GO.
IT WAS ADAM SCHIFF, REMEMBER,
FOR THREE YEARS, SEAN, MSNBC,
CNN AND EVERYWHERE HE COULD GET
SAYING COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
RUSSIANS AND DONALD TRUMP IS IN
PLAIN SIGHT.
PLAIN SIGHT!
WHY IS NO ONE ASKING WHERE THAT
IS IN TERMS OF BEING IN PLAIN
SIGHT?
THIS WEEK AND MORE INTERVIEWS,
ADMIT IT, THEY LIED.
THEY LIED BECAUSE I JUST DIDN'T
LIKE DONALD TRUMP REGARDLESS OF
THE POLICIES ON THE MOVING THE
NEEDLE.
>> Sean: WE NEED MARIA MOORE
WHEN SHE GETS UP AT 2:00 A.M.